hey y'all real quick before we dive into
this episode I think you're gonna enjoy
this one it was with our friend Courtney
Carver and man she is outstanding but
before we get into that today is an
exciting day for us we never plan to
create a physical good you know as the
minimalists creating a physical good it
seemed a bit ironic at first but after
receiving more than a thousand messages
about that discontinued travel bag in
our documentary the Netflix documentary
mentalism we decided to partner with the
man who created the original bag a guy
named Malcolm Vaughn ta - he's in he's
an environmentalist and he actually runs
a company called C hive that helps other
companies use less plastic and when
they're manufacturing things and he had
really similar values to us so we
decided to help Malcolm bring this bag
back for a a limited run the new version
of the bag is called the packed one it's
made responsibly from sustainable
materials and zero plastic packaging and
ships with no plastic whatsoever and
I'll tell you this it is honestly the
best bag that I have ever used and
that's why after seven years as the
minimalists it's our first and only
physical good it's the only physical
good that bears our name so if you're
interested in learning more about the
bag you can see a video we launched this
IndieGoGo campaign to try to figure out
how many people are going to want to
purchase or support this bag you can go
over to the minimalists comm slash bag
you can see the the links there you can
see a video about the bag all the
details but I want to be really clear
about this you probably don't need a new
bag and if you don't please don't feel
compelled to buy this one sure it for me
it makes travel a little bit simpler
it's truly one of the best items that
I've ever owned it's out of the most
value to my life but there's no physical
good that's going to make your life
happier or more complete so please
consider this bag only if you need a new
bag and only if you can afford it
otherwise it's okay to let it go it is
just a bag all right so we hope you
enjoy this
episode of the minimalists podcast
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me live from the Depot
theater in downtown Salt Lake City my
name is Joshua fields Milburn and I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists live in Salt Lake Ryan I got
to tell you our first tour stop was in
our first tour we came to Salt Lake as
one of the 33 cities we went to this was
2011 our first book had just come out
was called minimalism live a meaningful
life I remember that's so well and if
you yeah if you remember six people
showed up it was Josh and I that's - it
was Kourtney and her husband yes and
then it was two other folks we had two
people show up at our first Salt Lake
event and so a few extra have shown up
tonight thank you so much we've come
here almost every year since then and it
has become one of my favorite cities in
fact Ryan and I'd yeah we just moved to
Los Angeles and I have to tell you that
the city that was number two on the list
was we're sitting there right now
the deciding factor was one word winter
I have been committed to winter for the
last 36 years living in Ohio and Montana
and so I figured I'd have at least a bit
of a break before you know maybe maybe
settling down here someday but I
absolutely love this city I love the
people here and we have a special guest
with us tonight Ryan during his talk
earlier he was he was talking about some
of the people that inspired us early on
there was Colin and Leo and Joshua
Becker and and of course tonight's guest
who is a local hometown hero and someone
who inspired us she's the founder of her
websites called be more with less and
also project 333 please welcome to the
stage Cortney Carver
now Courtney you were just telling us
backstage you've been with us on
multiple continents now and I sort of
just looked at you and blinked for a
moment I forgot we were in Australia
together a few years ago and you've been
to quite a few of our stops oh thank you
for doing this tonight
we'll get it out in the the podcast
ether eventually but you're working on
something new right now we're working on
it with you it's called a simple year
and it's something we've we've worked on
with you a little bit it's your project
and we just sort of tag along and try to
help a few people out for a month but
it's 12 months of guided simplicity
what what what encouraged you to to go
down that route I mean it was it the
people that needed help and you couldn't
help them via email anymore but I
created a simple year because so many of
the changes I made were one at a time
and I noticed that we were putting so
much information out there on all the
amazing changes you can make and it was
almost overwhelming like where do we
start what do we do first
and I thought if we could break it down
topic by topic
month by month with amazing contributors
who really specialized in those topics
that it would give people some Direction
inspiration and accountability and a
little bit of fun along the way
so some of those topics are in fun is
the important part because for me like a
lot of the stuff if you just look it on
the surface when when I hear the word
decluttering I just sort of cringe at
this full-body wince like if you're one
of those people who really enjoys
decluttering I envy you I know there are
a few of you here here tonight but but
there are many of you who are like me
where you're like you like being a
result it's like I write for a living
that and most writers don't like writing
they like having written and so you like
the end result of like getting the stuff
out of the way I was actually we ran
into someone at a coffee shop earlier
today we were at a public coffee I
didn't give one woo for the
[Applause]
it's uh we were there and they the the
lady was talking like after seeing your
documentary which Kourtney's in by the
way and she said you know I didn't
realize that by getting rid of all this
stuff that I just wouldn't have to clean
as much and so I like that but the fun
part is like well you don't realize that
you can do something that is difficult
or maybe seems insurmountable at first
and actually enjoy the process and so
breaking it down to 12 to her months
where you have these 12 different topics
the one that Ryan and I work on is
gift-giving during the holiday season
because which by the way is right around
the corner and it's already too late for
those of you want to have it if you have
any questions about gifts tonight which
by the way if you do have questions as a
microphone right there you can line up
we'll take the first six questions
tonight if you have questions about
gifts hopefully it's for like next
summer words for someone's birthday
because now is the time to start talking
about gift-giving for for next year not
that the Christmas is already it's you
already have to go through whatever you
have to do at this point but um 12
months of guided simplicity we have some
details on our website about that is
called it just of minimalists calm /
simple year but Cortney what what
inspired you to move down this road of
of simplifying your life did you have an
inciting incident for you or were you
like Ryan where you just pissed off that
your best friend was happy I didn't mean
to simplify my life it wasn't what I set
out to do but in 2006 after months of
debilitating fatigue and vertigo
tingling in my hands some numbness in my
face and countless visits to the doctor
I was diagnosed with multiple sclerosis
and it was like my big wake-up call I
had had all of those symptoms before one
at a time and could easily explain them
I must have pinched a nerve I'm
of course I'm tired I'm so stressed out
there was always a reason and finally I
couldn't ignore those symptoms anymore
and decided to figure out how to live
well with MS and I wasn't like oh I
should just simplify my life and
everything will be great
instead my goal was to eliminate stress
a little bit at a time and as I did that
starting with diet moving to clutter
debt busyness I noticed that the common
thread and all of the changes I was
making was simplicity it feels like we
accidentally get to this complex place
in life and and it doesn't happen
overnight we're all of a sudden you
flipped a switch in your life is utterly
complex for me I look back when I was 28
and I'm like I want God I've got this
huge mortgage I'm underwater and I've
got two car payments I've got this job
that I'm stuck in that I don't hate but
I don't necessarily or honestly I was
failing my health and and we get to this
point of immense complexity by adding
sort of one brick on at a time so you've
built this house of this museum of
complexity and and in order to sort of
tear that down it's it's quite the
journey so where do you start I started
with diet the place where I knew it
would be the most difficult to change
but also the place where I thought I
could make the biggest difference and
while I'm not recommending this for me I
decided to cut meat out of my diet and
most animal products to really lower
that inflammation on the inside and it
worked it worked
and once I felt like that was the new
normal I moved on to the next most
stressful thing in my life which was
debt hundreds of thousands of dollars in
debt including our house whoo
yeah it wasn't an overnight debt-free
process you didn't just have hundreds of
thousand dollars sitting in a random
bank account you could pay stuff off
with most of us don't I certainly didn't
you mean he didn't just quit your job
and start a blog like we did I totally
did that no I didn't in fact I worked
and blogged and paid down debt all at
the same time for quite a while yeah and
I was I was just really inspired by it
by your story early on because I tell
you when I first stumbled across
minimalism was Colin Wright who's a
friend of ours but he was this 24 year
old single guy who travelled the world
and I'm like I really admire that but
man I really like having a sofa and and
so really Courtney I was just happy that
you had a sofa no I what I found is like
wow okay here's a different recipe you
at the time at a teenage daughter who by
the way Bailey she just graduated
college recently congratulations on that
thank you and yeah it's great and so I
realized like oh there are normal people
not just robots like Colin who has a
great podcast by the way it's called
let's know things you should check it
out but I realized that like wow here's
an actual normal person who who who made
me feel like this is more not just
attainable but practical for me and so
thank you for that you're welcome and I
should thank you Ryan because whenever
you share my story
I've been 40 for the last seven years
which I love thank you you're welcome
we're gonna film this eventually and
then we'll you'll be 40 forever love it
well let's answer you you willing to
stick around answer some questions with
us especially if we have some some
wardrobe questions I think tonight is
the night for that howdy what's your
name where you from and what's your
question hopefully in that order I'm Kim
I'm from Salt Lake and the pithy version
of my question is how do you know when
you've gone too far and the long version
is that I'm kind of a ruthless declutter
and it's been really easy and I haven't
had to do anything difficult yet but I
just wonder if one day I'll come home
from work and feel like I've been robbed
and then
and then realize that I did that to
myself
so so I'm hoping you have some advice on
how to make gradual and lasting change
but not to relapse and also not to
regret that I've chosen to live this way
can I ask you a question what what makes
you think that
by the way ruthless declutter ER is a
great blog name pick that up real quick
before someone's going to grab it what
makes you worried that are there outside
influences that are making you worried
or are you worried because you you see
some sort of sign on the horizon well of
course yeah everyone says I'm a fanatic
and thinks I'm crazy
yeah but but the trouble with getting
rid of things is then they're gone and
some things are replaceable but it may
be hard to figure out what is that now
sure
like what's irreplaceable that I mean I
agree with you there are some things
very replaceable but what kind of things
you're talking about like you didn't
know there's gonna be a conversation did
you know no I did I was like maybe you
have something that a friend gave you
and then something tragic happens to
them and now that item is way more
meaningful than you ever imagined it
would be sure and that's hard to know I
will pass this over to them but I'll
just say that the things have have only
the meaning that we give to them things
don't have intrinsic meaning and and I
know that will often use these words and
I'll even catch myself saying it
sometimes like oh that really means
something to me
well yeah because it's because I said it
means something to me or you'll hear me
say Idol yeah I love these pants but
then you'll also hear me say I love my
partner and it just doesn't add up like
we don't have the right vocabulary for
us sometimes right and and and so I
would just be careful with with the
vocabulary we use because if we say
something has meaning then all of a
sudden we think it does I saw this
amazing New Yorker cartoon where there
were these like two thieves and they
like hat you know like the cliche eye
masks on and they're both like carrying
a TV in this like super
empty room except for this gentleman who
is the homeowner and he's like tied with
his hot hands behind his back as they're
leaving and like the caption was this is
your chance to simplify don't screw it
up um you know I think that's probably a
little too extreme so let's start there
um it's anything like do you feel like
you're being too extreme right now not
yet no it's just I've gotten rid of
enormous amounts of stuff and it's just
cool very easy it's so easy how do you
feel right now I feel fine now but I
have to do anything awesome so I I guess
the reason why I asked that question the
question is because if there are people
out there who feel like they're at a
point where they're like I've gotten rid
of too many things chances are they've
probably gotten rid of too many things
and there are these internal feelings
and voices that go on that we do have to
listen to there's no doubt about it
in fact even with those heirlooms that
you're talking whether you know a family
member who is alive or now life gave you
something or anyone listening to this
there might be something that you know
someone is holding on to or they're like
oh man but you know this is like a quilt
of this is actually a legitimate example
we had pretty recently at one of our
stops where their mother had made all of
this quilt out of high school pictures
so it was like you know this this this
girl and her friends and her prom dates
in her car and like for her it was this
very sentimental quilt and meant a lot
but she kept it in her closet in like
she was you know I don't know how old
she was when we she was after high
school I'll just say that and it got to
a point where she was just keeping this
angle in the closet because it was
embarrassing for her to have it out she
didn't want to have to explain every
single story it was something in the met
to her when she was in high school but
now she you know she's a professional
woman and like did not want to have this
you know high school quilt hanging out
and I asked her I'm like hey
would you do if like you know you you
sat back down in your seat and then you
got a text from your neighbor and it was
like man I hate to tell you this but
like your back your house like it there
was this fire in there and it was your
quilt it's spontaneously combusted but
it was the only thing that burn up like
that was it like how would that make you
feel and she was like man that would
really make me feel relieved so I I
think those feelings and those voices
that we have or you know there's
internal voices that we have like we
really do have to at least give it a
little bit of attention and merit and
say like is this actually hitting on
something that is going to have this
this lasting damage on my life and for
her that internal voice was like no let
go but you know there may be something
there where I'm trying to think of this
really awesome example where I'm like I
have this one thing in my house I can
never let go but I'm one of the
minimalists so of course I don't know I
you know what if I did I would totally
tell you or if you do it's not yours you
just say it's Mariah right exactly
Bryce got this bowling ball collection
she just loves Homer Simpson my Bob
Marge a bowling ball on the Simpsons and
it said Homer on it and he said if you
don't want to use it I know someone who
will Courtney of you have that is not
that is not ours it's not how we lived
okay according to have you ever felt
like you've gone too far
I haven't and what's interesting is that
not only don't I miss anything that I've
gotten rid of but I can't remember a lot
of it and when we moved from our house
to an apartment less than half the size
I had probably five or six pretty
sizeable boxes of things I wasn't ready
to let go of and I just wrote on the
boxes save put in storage decide later I
wrote decide later on the box in case I
forgot what I was supposed to do
and when we found the apartment that we
really wanted there was no storage space
that came with the apartment and I
thought well if I buy extra storage
space like my blog is gonna go down the
- I can't do that
so instead more with storage.com
somebody get that right now so I got rid
of everything that was in those boxes
and if you were to offer me ten thousand
a hundred thousand a million dollars
right now to tell you what was in those
boxes
I couldn't and that's only been four
years four and a half years Wow and I
don't remember what was so important
that I had to decide later those boxes
yeah thanks your question thank you
howdy what's your name Oh Megan I'm from
Salt Lake also a fan girl my friends are
making fun of me right now so sorry to
be the weirdo in the front row but ya
know they appreciate you being here in
the front row thank you so
oh we love it you imagine that no one
was in the front row that would be so
awkward we did the 30 day challenge the
three of us and we had a good time so
thank you for the one who won Brandee
middle well Brandis hardcore though
she's like the Kim before she likes
she's the one-upper of the friends
that's how Josh she's just naturally
minimal and I'm not so um my question is
I hope not to nichy I work from home and
I work in an industry I love and doing
something I love so I don't want to just
ditch it but it means FedEx boxes come
to me
frequently almost daily sometimes and I
make a product and it sounds so nerdy
but a professional scrapbooker and
writer and yeah well um so you know I'm
actually telling my real stories of my
family and my children and I don't want
to ditch it but if I it's really hard to
keep on top of it it's coming in faster
and I can cycle it out and when my home
is my office I just feel like I'm
sinking and I found you through of
course like so many of us a documentary
and since then I've been very hyper
aware of it before I had my bunny trails
which is so awful to admit but you I
just you don't see it when it's around
you so much you're kind of blinders on
you took those off for me but then
something like now I'm suffocating right
because I do see it and I can't stop its
I need it to make the money's alright so
I hope I'm this relates for some people
the monies are important the monies are
good the monies are good Josh and I are
not allergic the money and the
scrapbooks are good I like what I do so
you need to tell me you love what you do
I do
but you still have to work every day
well I don't know if I call it I mean I
make money for it so I guess in this but
what you're describing it sounds like
work like keeping track of it all and
making oh that aspect yes the management
of it yes it work the output and the end
result I don't feel like it's work right
the writing yes - am I right or what I'm
done writing I love the piece kidding
there's pain and and that's kind of what
I'm getting at it yes
you know it's man I certainly do have
some like tips for you but here's just
want to say one thing okay um we we are
raised and especially like in the
Western world with this whole saying of
if you find something that you love to
do or they really like to do you'll
never have to work a day in your life
it's [ __ ] now there's someone here
in the audience or maybe listening to
this whenever we come out with this
podcast and they're saying no no no I
wake up I love what I do and I don't
work a day in my life I'm so jealous of
that person like I think I think it's
probably possible but probably not
plausible for everyone in here in this
room to have that that type of attitude
so I guess what uh what I want to say to
you is is like embrace the work that has
to come with that end result like Drudge
through that drudgery that the tips I
want to give you is like better
organization I okay so well that's why
we're here to help Josh so Ryan and I
have different personalities Ryan has
considered starting a blog called the
messy minimalist I'm sure someone's
smash that up yeah it's the minimalist
ish calm
we're gonna have some of the URLs Sean I
hope you're snatching these up right now
no I I don't really understand what
you're struggling with exactly your
scrapbook page you need paper and
buttons and ribbon and you know all
these now you're patronizing me no no I
don't require products and so those
companies in this industry shipped me
products and I make things well why is
that a problem I get I get boxes from
Amazon on my house occasionally I don't
I guess the volume okay I do sometimes
one thing what do you do with her day
what'd he do with all the chocolate that
they send backs for free oh yeah my
partner Rebecca runs a blog called
minimal wellness and chocolate thank you
she's the best and she will occasionally
get like really great chocolate sent to
the house like cases of great chocolates
yeah there's a company called tazza that
makes amazing chocolate and they've not
paid me anything because you can't pay
me anything to sponsor the podcast but
they sent like 14 pounds of chocolate to
the house and all of it was delicious
that night
Josh gained 14 pounds that evening yeah
and I mean here's the thing I i'm i
understand i don't live a zero-waste
lifestyle i admire people who do and i
consume a lot less than i ever have so
that when i do consume it's intentional
and i certainly don't feel bad about the
little waist that i produce it sounds to
me like you've radically reduced other
areas of life you know whether it's with
the 30 day minimalism game or elsewhere
in your life and that means you've
radically reduced the amount of
consumption you have i don't think you
necessarily have to feel bad about the
the waste your by the way you're
producing a lot of recyclable waste
which is is also good you're not dumping
plastic into the ocean that's a
completely different thing there's not
even an ocean really around here man
Great Salt Lake tasted like the ocean no
and so here's the other thing the
question I'll challenge you with a
little bit is is there a way for you to
acquire what you need to acquire and
produce less waste and I don't have to
answer that question right now you need
to ask that question of yourself a lot
over the next month it really makes me
think of like an artist who has all of
these art supplies like I have talked to
people in the past who are like but man
like I totally I have like you know 60
grocery plastic bags I don't know what
to do with I'm gonna make art with them
one day and I got all these vinyl
records and these cassette tapes and
don't even get me started on the paints
I have you know a closet full of you
know paint floor-to-ceiling and and I
you know one day I'm going to make art
out of this stuff and at the end of the
day like they're never gonna use all
that stuff so for for for you or an
artist who is really trying to figure
out you know what do I hold on to what
do I let go of which by the way letting
go yes you can recycle it if you have a
scrapbooking business I bet you you have
like
friends and family and students do stuff
right yeah you could like totally
distribute this stuff towards like to
find it the better home but you know for
the stuff that you really look at you're
like man that's really that's a really
cool stapler and like I am gonna use
that star that star shaped yes right no
I get it
I love me star shaped stapled love it my
tape dispensers I have like seven or
eight right but if you know you've got
to make a rule you've got to make a rule
for yourself and I don't know what that
is I mean for me I use a 90-day rule
it's you know like we just moved
recently Josh and I both moved out to LA
at Mariah and I as we were moving into
our place it just doesn't have as much
like you know storage space for pots and
pans and and like our drunk our junk
drawer are drunk drawer what Freud say
that by the way that's where he keeps
the liquor you're right but our junk
drawer let me tell you about that no it
is it's like it's about half as big and
it's funny because like we put
everything in there I'm like why is this
a small of a sudden like oh it's good
because it's smaller so I you know we
had to go through that and I'm like all
right like what have we not used in the
last three months and you know there's
like some you know warranty in there
from whatever product and Mariah's like
hey Ryan like we you put this in the
drunk drawer and you know he always does
that you put this in there you know six
months ago when we were living in
Montana do you think we're actually
gonna use this at like am I gonna use
that warranty in the next 90 days I'm
like yeah probably not
and so we will start filtering through
stuff like that so maybe 90 days maybe
that's not your your limit but figure
out what that limit is like what is your
drunk drawer limit let's not go there
and probably it probably is 90 days by
the way corn you anything that I'm just
trying to figure out I'm gonna put my
drunk chore
thanks P question thank you before we
move on to the next one real quick if
you're listening to this at home you
have a comment or tip for anyone who
asks a question today you can give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine it's my favorite part
of the show at the very end where people
start leaving their own comments and
tips because I learn a lot many things
that I steal and repurpose later recycle
them for later use you can also send a
voicemail right from your phone podcast
at the minimalists comm is the email
address and we'll post some of our
favorite comments and tips at the end of
every episode here's a handful at the
end of the episode so stay tuned for
that Ryan do you know what time it is oh
man let me check yes it is time for our
hashtag ask the minimalist lightening
around where usually we answer questions
from social media but that would be
weird if we were on our phones up here
on stage so we'll keep going with the
line yeah so usually we do is we try to
wrap it up in a bow a nice pithy hundred
and forty character answer all I've been
told that's gonna change to two hundred
eighty characters oh my god we're gonna
be if brevity is the soul of wit then we
are half-wits
but we try to give you 140 character
answer that you can tweet by the way
jess is around here somewhere jess
handles our social media makes it look
really beautiful
she doesn't outstanding job and she live
tweets from these events you can give
her give her a round of applause thank
you
[Applause]
she's taking photos tonight she's also a
live tweet so you can check that hashtag
lessons now you can post your own photos
using that same hashtag and she'll
repost and retweet and reshare and Yik
yak and whatever you kids are doing
these days she's on it she's our
resident millennial and and oh you
picked the answers we'll give you the
last 140 characters but because we're on
stage it takes a while so we ramble on
so Courtney if you'll ramble long with
us a bit and then maybe we'll try to tie
up each little answer with a with 140
characters and and and maybe even turn
into a competition if my answers are
good enough howdy what's your name hey
Jessica so you touched on a couple of
points that relate to my question
because for several years I have worked
for a professional organizer who happens
to be my mother and and it's it's just
kind of crazy like the the industry
where like like you have no idea how
happy she was when The Container Store
came to Utah and and they even have like
the campaign like the contained home
campaign where they pair clients with
professional organizers to organize
their spaces and they will literally
spend thousands if not tens of thousands
of dollars on like that designs the
system's the containers do we labor in
the labor that all go into organizing
their spaces and and I'm just used to
those people who are looking for those
like one-time solutions like give me the
container
give me the label give me the shelf here
you go
yeah so my pit the answer for you then
I'll expand on it my pit the answer is
organizing is well planned hoarding
Thanks
but here's here's what I'll actually
tell you most professional organizers
the ones who get it they actually
understand that they here's my second
pit the answer the easiest way to
organize your stuff is to get rid of
most of it and I mean what thanks but
once you realize that but the problem
was I didn't realize that so I had a
basement full of stuff and The Container
Store was my friend I had an ordinal
system of boxes and bins and crates and
it was a maze of I don't even know what
the hell was in my basement honestly
dude it was like 50 gallon rubber maids
yeah in a ping pong table there was a
ping-pong table you had to walk through
the maze of The Container Store that was
in my basement I had like a container
store satellite location and I just said
I mean I had double XL shirts from when
I weighed 80 pounds more than I weigh
now every time I went to Josh's house
was like dude you might like this tie we
got the same shoe size you might want to
these pairs and he's like okay and and
that's how I minimized
Courtney I'm so gonna win this one if
you need new stuff to store your stuff
too much stuff I actually didn't finish
my question yet but I appreciate that
it was just a bit of bags no no you're
done next question yeah I'm kidding I'm
kidding but so again like most people
are looking for that like one-time
solution and then and so I'm I am kind
of used to just you know doing the labor
that goes into that but lately I do have
people approaching me from a place of
vulnerability saying I need to let go of
this stuff it's too overwhelming and I'm
drowning like what can I do and so I'm
just wondering what you recommend for
supporting those people not as a hard
professional but more as a friend Josh
well I'm really gonna let Ryan answer
this because we I ever already felt like
Courtney and I gave really good answers
but but I think I think the best way to
be a good friend is to be honest yeah I
it's funny
here's my pithy answer that I had going
in my head sometimes on the P what's
that
bring on the pit I'll bring on the
pitting here it is sometimes a person
doesn't realize they're not that thirsty
until they're drowning and what I'll say
to kind of a company that was damn good
but really that's my way of saying is
that sometimes there are friends and
there are family members and there are
clients who are really vying and really
craving your support it's sometimes you
got to give it to them and it's okay to
support someone as long as it's not
going outside of your values and beliefs
but if you have someone asking you for
help and they realize they're like oh
[ __ ] I'm not thirsty I am drowning then
that is your opportunity to start doing
very simple things like hey hey let's
play the 30-day minimalism game I heard
about this thing from the minimalists no
you could totally do the thirty minimum
30-day minimalism game you could do one
thing you know a day for a month
whatever it may good sorry we are
currently on Facebook actually started
October 1st doing the 30-day clutter
clear out on Facebook so you've already
you've already helped these people start
yeah then why are you asking this
question I just want to say the the
great thing is you're you're just in
such a tremendous place to help because
they are asking you and so often the
question that I know I get and I'm sure
you guys get is how do we convince
someone else that this is the right way
to do things but how do I force my
husband to be a minimalist I don't have
one of those so so you're just they're
already asking you for help so you can
share your story why you were inspired
and then encourage and and and as soon
as they kind of get a taste for the
relief that comes from less yeah cuz my
my question just kind of has to do with
I'm used to the like 9 out of 10 people
who're you know asking for the like do
this do this like the basic bits in
regards to organizing but then it's like
how do i best provide the emotional
support so it's kind of it yeah I I
think I think it has more to do with
questions then you know during my talk I
talked about some of the questions I
asked myself early on but the first
question was how am I my life be better
with less and helping them understand
that because what you're telling me is
people are some people are overwhelmed
that 1 out of 10 is overwhelmed and and
because they're overwhelmed it's they're
in that state of Perales
right and they feel like they can't
start because they don't have the
leverage they need to start and what you
need to do to support them is help them
find that leverage thank you thank you
Thanks howdy hi what's your name Tracy
Tracy and I'm from Salt Lake City but
really from California and I saw you
guys in California is everyone here from
Salt Lake don't we have anyway South
Ogden or something I know those people
from Provo
so I had 30 minutes to get here Joshua
James lives in American Fork really he's
a really talented musician anyone know
one yeah
by the way best music in the country is
in Utah but uh I'm sorry I've digress
yeah okay I'm gonna say three things
number one I love your message so much
thank you so much it's like makes my
heart so happy and some grateful the
second thing I want to say is um I I'm a
minimalist at heart I'm a sip I'm a
simple person I like plain Hershey bars
everything's simple I loves him
and so a couple of Christmases ago I'm
like I didn't give any presents to my
kids in California or any of my other
kids I have seven by the way twelve to
thirty and I am I gave them the gift
most the people in here have seven kids
that is true that is true but they have
not as many we get another one offer so
last year at the same time no one at a
time
too soon dude kind of more than you
would guess so wait wait so so a lot so
a couple Christmases ago I gave the gift
of my presents because I think I think
showing up is such a gift and then this
year I gave my kids all of my kids in my
family a portrait where we all took
pictures of beach over the summer and
they're all getting USB drives and one
picture that I create for them so but so
that was like I'm so I'm so well most
gratitude one was letting you know that
you have so touched my life and I have
implemented it even more than my heart
has already implemented it on its own
the third thing I want to ask you was
what is the one thing that you like
treasure is there one thing each of you
really cares about that you would value
more that's a thing not a person because
I'm all about love without condition but
is there something because I could take
a picture of everything I can remember
everything and I honestly just like live
in a cardboard box with pictures us
because I can go to the library and plug
that in and look at the pictures my
ex-wife sent me a picture earlier this
year of my John Stockton rookie card
by the way greatest basketball player of
all time you didn't get that in the
divorce issues tossing rain I still got
this you son of a [ __ ] no we actually
really care about each other chief I
found this somewhere and the funny thing
is like I used to really like love this
thing it had so much meaning to me and
the truth is like I really did I was a
huge Utah Jazz fanatic and I didn't even
remember that I had that damn thing ten
years later and it's similar to what
Courtney was talking about earlier and
and and so if I were to give you a pithy
answer it it would have something to do
with letting go as a muscle so the more
you flex it the stronger no Dan you flex
your muscles a lot man what do you do
what are you doing down in that green
room are you intimidated a little bit
Pass
[Laughter]
the short answer to your question is is
no like I don't love that oh my goodness
I love that but you know uh I have I it
is a muscle that I have flexed but you
know over the last seven years like I
really have got to a point where our
here's my pet the answer my treasures
have nothing to do with who I am as a
person so uh I would I would say like
continue to practice that and like you
will get to that point like I didn't
seven years ago it was it was about
eight and a half years ago when I asked
Josh to that question like why the hell
are you so happy but there wasn't a
switch that was just flipped overnight
it's not like I'm like oh yeah
minimalism perfect let's do that and
then we'll do the minimalists calm and
talked about minimalism I mean for me it
was this it was very common sense it was
very much like oh yeah if I don't have
all this debt if I don't buy a new car
every couple of years if I don't rack up
all this credit card debt like maybe I
won't have to work 80 hours a week and
like sell my soul to this place so it
started out very very small but from
implementing that over I don't know how
long it takes but it seven years I
promise you you'll get it no honey I
don't know nothing I'm so simple so
what's the thing that you hold on to
that you're like love it can never can
never ever live without it nothing oh
there we go
yeah nice Kourtney is there anything
that you treasure so much you could
never ever let it go I'm not gonna say
never ever but I do have a thing and I
at first I was gonna say nothing as well
and then I thought how happy I am when I
push the button on my coffee machine in
the morning so my coffee machine
is one of those things that I really
enjoy owning you know what I see now you
say that I would say my eight cell phone
only because it has the pictures of the
people I love and I can Facebook and see
the people I adore from kindergarten and
then I can call the people I love that's
really good but it's a tool it is the
tool to the people I love first off it's
for the love of God go back up your
photos because if you ever lose that
cell phone that's really gonna be I've
done that before I'm like oh man that
was like when I was in the corporate
world my phone like I did not back up
the Hawaii photos and I was uh you know
I was like [ __ ] I really wish I mean now
I don't really regret it but five
thousand pictures of my phone go back
that you Brian
all right add that my coffeemaker was
also a tool for the people I love I
gotta move on though I know God but I
will say my motto in my whole family is
if you're grateful for what you have
you're the richest person in the world I
love that yes thank you thank you very
much appreciate you being on comments
one sec one sec all right so before we
move on it's time for our added value
segments usually Ryan and I we talk
about something that has added value to
our lives recently well it's where we
talked about all our sponsors have you
been have you been having a hard night's
sleep have you been having a hard time
shaving close to the skin hey Ryan let
me tell you about the softest sheets
you'll ever sleep on so people laughing
right now the people who listen to other
podcasts but let's talk real quick about
what's added value to our lives recently
in fact by us not doing sponsors on the
podcast allows us to very genuinely talk
about things that we've enjoyed but
since we're here locally let's talk
about some things that I enjoy and Ryan
I know enjoys whenever we come to this
town whenever we're on tour we go
looking for great food and great coffee
so Ryan what's been added value to your
life and Salt Lake City Utah have you
seen the architecture
here in Salt Lake it's the best in the
country god I freaking love this city
like it's it's the air Sant sans
inversion the air is frickin awesome I
really do love it is that funny is that
is that funny okay sorry it's the second
edit that out you know what I love about
Salt Lake guys not the air you're damn
right Josh uh no there are so many
things I love about Salt Lake I will
tell you like the one thing I freaking
love about this city is I'm not even a
vegan but there's this vegan restaurant
called sages cafe oh I have I have to
eat there every single time I'm here
even though like I again like I'm not
vegan I was for a year on a bet with
Josh I won I gave him the dollar no you
didn't dude he still owes me a dollar
you're not getting it no sages cafe if
you haven't checked it out do yourself a
favor like do it go to sages it's it's
unbelievable they have a sister cafe or
a brother cat I don't know what you call
it what's it called
oh yeah vertical yes vertical all right
so uh Josh and I have been doing this
like this ketogenic thanks a vertical
isn't really ketogenic meaning they
serve the most amazing diner food you've
ever had it's like biscuits and gravy
little or literally vegan style which is
unbelievable but that would totally give
me like ten extra pounds on my hips so I
haven't been there but if you can afford
to eat the greasy spoon stuff and you're
vegan like the vertical is freakin
unbelievable - oh yeah well my favorite
coffee shops in the country is a place
called blue copper and it's not too far
from here and so I'm sure some of you
also have other recommendations in fact
we were there the other day and I ran
into one of my favorite musicians just I
don't know I mean I really loved the
music scene here - J William Henderson
is a really talented musician I know if
he's here tonight he said he's gonna
show up yeah it was yesterday and Josh
was like dude if you bring a guitar you
will open that's
quite often we have we have openers play
some music and surprise people but we
can get the person we wanted to get here
anyway so yeah if you get if you get if
you enjoy coffee I know some of you
don't and that's okay stop judging me
they have a great decaf too is what I
was going to say okay let's move on the
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalists bunch stuff going on we
talked about a simple year so we're
doing the 12 months of guided simplicity
with Cortney and a bunch of other
simplicity experts and you can find that
at the minimalists comm slash simple
year I think early registration ends
November 14th you got it it just started
like a couple days ago so if you're
interested in and here's the thing that
I'll be the first to tell you I don't
think you need a course to simplify your
life I mean simplify your life on your
own if you feel like you needed a little
guided help I think it's helped out a
lot of people in the past but it's not
something you absolutely have to have if
you need some help it's there for you
alright you a quick interruption if you
want to listen to our bonus episode this
week as well as all of our past bonus
episodes head on over to the minimalists
dot-com and click donate at the top of
our website each week we publish the
minimalists private podcast exclusively
for our patreon supporters this private
podcast shows up in your normal podcast
feed like Apple podcasts overcast Google
Play or whatever podcast app you use and
it shows up right next to our normal
weekly podcast you know the one you're
listening to right now and being a
patreon supporter also gets you first
access to the best tickets to all of our
live events as well as access to our
monthly private livestream video which
is called ask the minimalists anything
it's worth noting that none of this
money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast and film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee
but it is your support that keeps his
podcast 100% advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2% of our audience to support this
show then we'll have enough funds to
produce some amazing new creations your
support is truly appreciated alright
y'all back to the regular show oh by the
way I'm what was her name
dammit her name was not dammit you're
right yeah I think I think that when
we're when we're in the moment so so for
those of you who aren't listening to the
private podcast that we just recorded
when we're sort of in the moment
everything feels overwhelming and
everything can become an excuse to to to
get into more debt or to not get get out
of that we were talking about that I
think that I think that we confuse
self-care with just taking care of
yourself and and and those things mo
sounds like a tautology but but when we
we take care of ourselves generally it
doesn't cost nearly as much as we think
in fact too often we spend a lot of
money to get us into an unhealthy
situation and so think about that debt
is incredibly unhealthy because it calls
a stress anxiety discontent and it keeps
you tethered to a place where you may
not want to be tethered and I want to
take a few people before we wrap up
while we're on the road we have someone
who helps us with a whole lot of stuff
podcast editing podcast recording tour
manager tour bus driver and an
all-around outstanding human being
ladies and gentlemen podcast Shawn is
hiding in the shadows of the back
I want to thank Courtney Carver for
being here tonight thank you so much for
being part of this and how about this
theater tonight the depot ladies and
gentlemen and if you leave here with
just one message tonight we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works
thanks for being here y'all thanks so
much Salt Lake thank you so much you
guys are awesome all right before we
listen to these comments from our
listeners wanted to remind y'all that
Ryan and I are on the road right now we
have some tour stops coming up we're
gonna finish up the year in Tennessee
Washington DC Georgia Florida Michigan
and Wisconsin and most of those are
selling out or are already sold out and
then in January January 14th we have a
charity event to help out the Las Vegas
Victims Fund it's going to be the House
of Blues in Las Vegas it's not on our
tour page yet but you can sign up for
our e-mail and be the first to hear
about that actually our patreon
supporters will be the the very first to
hear about it look at presale access to
all that and then next year we're going
to be in Australia and New Zealand we've
already announced for cities and guess
what we might even do a for a while a
few more cities for you so check out les
is now calm that's our tour page and you
can sign up for our email list over
there if I didn't mention any of your
states or cities or countries and you
will be one of the first to know about
any new tour stops all right enjoy these
comments and tips from our listeners hi
this is Debbie from Canberra Jenny
I have a message for Lila from Edmonton
who was talking about her to over 1 year
old who's going to be a two-year-old
next birthday and I had a suggestion if
you want to encourage people to not give
her things but maybe experiences you can
be very specific about the kinds of
would be great so for example you could
say you know we'd love to give her a
swimming lessons this year and each
swimming lesson works out to this much
money so if you'd like to give her a
swimming lesson you know send us about a
feature with some money and then the
other suggestion is to follow up so you
know throughout the year send people a
message with a photo of her at swimming
lessons to let them know that that gift
was used and it was appreciated and so
they can actually see the result of
giving someone an experience rather than
a physical items hey Josh and Ryan
Brad in New York here I have suggestions
to people trying to get rid of items he
doesn't necessarily have to be a
physical object deleting superfluous
apps from your phone can count to
digital clutter is still clutter hey
guys my name is Justin and I'm calling
from Columbus Ohio and my question has
to do with prescription medication so
hopefully you guys are aware in your
home home state of Ohio that the opioid
prescription crisis is at a all-time
high
when it comes to the abuse and misuse of
prescription medication and one of the
things that's been developed through the
Ohio State University is a program
called generation rx and one of the key
takeaways is educating the public about
the proper use of prescription
medication as well as a proper disposal
so when you getting listening to your
guys's podcast and learning about some
of the principles that you guys you know
are teaching on it it can be applied to
to help as a potential solution for this
crisis and by applying the simplifying
and minimalizing
your drug cabinet or your medicine
cabinet and going through and properly
disposing of prescription medications
that aren't being used because one out
of four people that miss user
abuse of prescription drug got him from
a family member a friend a lot of times
that's just prescription drugs that are
hanging out in the medicine cabinet
not know that can be minimized when
they're no longer needed
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
you're green oh I bet that you'll be
fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
eyes or too
[Music]
you